we've talked about young people
a little bit at the beginning of our
conversation
is there advice that you could give
to a young person today thinking about
their career thinking about their life
thinking about uh making their way in
this world
yeah sure i'll share some advice it
actually picks up on a question we
talked about
earlier with in in the academy in
schools
but it's some advice that a professor
gave to
me when i got to harvard
and it is this that uh you have to be
willing to come face to face with your
intellectual limitations
and keep going and that's it and it's
hard for people i mean you mentioned
this earlier
to to face really difficult tasks to
uh and particularly in these sort of
elite spaces where you've excelled all
your life
and you come to mit and you're like wait
a minute i don't understand this
yeah wait this is hard i've never had
something really hard before and there
are couple options and a lot of people
will
pull back and take the gentleman or just
a woman's b
and and just go on or risk
going out there giving it your all and
still not quite getting it
and that that that's a risk but it's a
risk well worth it
uh because you're just going to be the
better person the better student for it
and
you know and even outside of the academy
i mean come come
face to face with your uh fears
and keep going and keep going in in life
and you're going to be the better
person the better uh human being yeah it
does seem to be
i don't know what it is but it does seem
to be that fear
is a good indicator of something you
should
probably face
yes like fear kind of shows the way a
little bit
uh not always you might not want to go
into the cage with a lion but
but maybe you should maybe
you